Speaker 1: Today, I'm going to be speaking
with Spencer Head Worth, who's assistant professor
of sociology at Purdue University, affiliated
scholar of the American Bar Foundation, also
author of the book Policing Welfare Punitive,
Adversarial ISM in Public Assistance.
It's great to have you on.
I really appreciate your time.
Speaker 5: Thanks for having me.
It's good to be here.
Speaker 1: So, you know, I think maybe to
get us into this conversation, oftentimes
in popular culture, people will point to the
Ronald Reagan stories about welfare queens
as really raising the level of suspicion around
welfare programs and so-called free riders.
How far back can we trace that suspicion about
people receiving benefits they don't really
deserve and this type of idea?
Speaker 5: Sure.
So it goes back about as far as organized
poverty relief programs go back.
So you're going to look at English poor law
in the 15th century and the fourteen hundreds
in England.
And in those very early versions of assistance
programs, there were provisions for inspectors
basically to check up on people and see if
they were drinking or gambling with the assistance
that they were getting from the state.
And in the United States, again, attracts
back to the kind of earliest versions of public
assistance programs that were out there.
And in the 20th century, when we get food
stamps, the predecessor to snap, the kind
of earliest food stamp provisions included
checking on people to see if they were violating
rules.
And there's a long history that's intertwined.
There really is is almost no historical period
where welfare programs did not include some
kind of suspicion checking evaluation types
of mechanisms.
That said, it certainly does ramp up in the
Reagan administration, in the United States
as a politically and popularly salient issue
and a period when we get several key legal
changes.
Speaker 1: So if a certain program has requirements
in order to qualify, it seems intuitive that
you would have some mechanism for policing
that and ensuring that the people that are
getting the benefits actually qualify.
Now, in in some theoretical sense, if one
eliminated all of this bureaucracy for policing,
there's some cost to that bureaucracy.
In theory, it might actually, in the net cost
less not to worry about the so-called free
riders and eliminate the cost of the bureaucracy.
Has that been studied with any particular
programs?
Speaker 5: So economists have looked into
this, at least to some degree, with regard
to UBI type of system, right, a universal
basic income, the idea of taking a means tested
program like SNAP like ten, if that we have
now, and completely eliminating the expenses
associated with the policing mechanisms, it's
really hard to tell.
You can do some things, some very basic, you
know, back of the napkin.
How much are we recovering?
Poor investigation type of math, but that
does not take account for whatever deterrent
effect the existence of fraud investigation
has, the kind of broader symbolic components
of the system that have an influence on people's
behavior, which there is some influence.
But it's really hard to determine how.
It's the kind of counterfactual where we don't
have these programs, we don't have data, really.
Right.
So it's tough to say.
And for the book I The Primary did our interviews
with people who work in fraud investigation
investigators and data analysts and managers
of these units and so forth.
And they, you know, perhaps unsurprisingly,
given it's their job, but they think that
that deterrent effect, which is hard to measure,
is is really substantial.
So it's hard to say
Speaker 1: in in in policing by law enforcement.
We have many examples of how a law or a statute
can just kind of be written agnostically on
paper, but can be applied in discriminatory
ways or selectively.
Can you talk a little bit about when it comes
to policing of welfare programs, does the
same thing apply?
And if so, how do we see kind of the discriminate
discriminative application of some of these
programs of policing mechanisms, rather?
Speaker 5: So there are ways that these programs,
the way some of the ways that these programs
function, do have some implications, I think,
for inequities in who's investigated, who's
potentially charged with welfare fraud, who
has these charges substantiated against them.
You know, I will note that all of the or nearly
all of the people that I spoke to were adamant
that they do not discriminate on the basis
of race.
They have no feelings about that one way or
the other.
One of the basic facts here is that they mostly
investigate women because women are disproportionately
participants in the program.
So there's that there's that difference.
Speaker 1: I guess the question there would
be, are they investigated at a greater rate
than their level of participation?
Speaker 5: They they don't keep statistics
on the characteristics of the people that
they investigate.
They told me that they don't.
So I can't say that for sure.
I can say that, for example, being a person
with children as opposed to a person without
children has at least some effect on increasing
your likelihood of becoming the subject of
a serious investigation.
So the one of the basic mechanisms here is
they're trying to figure out which cases are
most promising so they have more potential
investigations and they can pursue.
So they choose which ones to go after.
Right.
And one of the main things that they're looking
for is a higher dollar value.
So if you're the head of a household with
children, you're probably getting a higher
dollar value in benefits than if you're not.
So that's an example of just kind of a mathematical
risk factor.
Another thing that's going on here is the
cases that are most promising to investigate
are cases with more evidentiary availability.
Right.
So if you can get more information about a
person, you're more likely to spend more time
on that investigation to make it a priority
because you can get more access to evidence
that you can use to substantiate your charges.
So that means if you are, quote unquote on
paper in various ways already with government
agencies, whether that be criminal justice
agencies, agencies of the welfare state, whatever
it is, if you have kids in school, all of
these are potential sources of information
that welfare fraud investigators can draw
upon to figure out how much money you make,
who lives in your house, these kinds of things.
So being more recorded by the state has this
sort of implication of also making you potentially
more interesting, you know, someone to investigate
because this evidence is out there in ways
it might not be for someone who's less recorded
with the state.
Speaker 1: When we talk about fraud, people,
oftentimes the application processes for these
programs are not particularly simple.
And there is, it seems to me, at least in
intent, a big difference between fraud and
errors made during the application process.
Can you talk a little bit about whether mistakes
and errors or information that has since changed
are considered fraud under this general umbrella?
Speaker 5: So, I mean, first I would flag
the person whose research is probably the
best on this is Karen Gusterson, who wrote
a book called Cheating Welfare.
That's one of the inspirations for this book
that came out a few years ago with NYU Press.
And, you know, she focuses on clients.
And so she she does pretty deeply into this
question of intent and the construction of
intent.
And when is a mistake just a mistake?
One thing that I can say for sure from my
evidence and comparing it with previous work
like Corrine's that looks at the client side
is that the investigators are much more likely
to see things as intentional and present them
as intentional than our right.
And that is in part due to the structural
factors pertaining here.
So they are the individual investigators and
the broader units of which they are parts
are incentivized to get intentional program
violation charges, intentional fraud charges.
Those are the sort of most rewarding for them
professionally.
They also garner financial rewards for the
state from the federal government when you
can substantiate these types of charges.
So there are things that I think are borderline
that are constructed as intentional.
And I mean, the broad, you know, sort of baseline
understanding here is that if you provide
a piece of information to the agency and sign
your application form saying that everything
that you've sworn to hear is accurate and
up to date, and then later they find evidence,
whether it's from the Department of Labor
or the Department of Motor Vehicles or a privately
maintained database of some kind, wherever
they get it, if they find that evidence that
contradicts whatever you put on your signed
statement, that is generally considered probative
proof of intentional fraud.
Speaker 1: And what is the process for adjudicating
something like that?
Speaker 5: So in nineteen seventy six, the
US Supreme Court ruled in Goldberg vs. Kelley
that welfare benefits are a form of property
and that therefore participants in the program
are entitled to some version of due process
before benefits can be terminated.
So the way that that works when you're accused
of an intentional program violation is in
a setting.
It's called an administrative hearing, administrative
disqualification hearing perhaps that is overseen
by an administrative hearing officer that
is the equivalent of a judge.
And that's where the client gets an opportunity
to come in and potentially argue against whatever
allegations are being made, present their
own evidence.
If they have evidence that contradicts the
evidence that the welfare fraud investigator
gathered and then the administrative hearing
officer makes a determination of whether the
state has met their burden of proof in establishing
clear and convincing evidence of an intentional
program violation.
So that's one of the things that welfare fraud
investigators have to learn how to navigate
and negotiate is how to work in these settings,
getting to know the particular hearing officers
and what kind of standards they have.
And it's, you know, one sort of advantage
that a fraud investigator has over a client
is they're more familiar with the second they
potentially know the hearing officer.
They've been there before.
They know, you know, Miss Jones likes this
kind of evidence.
Mr. Smith doesn't like this kind of evidence
right now.
They're more inclined to do this or that.
So that's the that's the setting where these
things are adjudicated.
And one of the things that fraud investigators
learn is how to navigate and negotiate in
those spaces.
Speaker 1: One of the things I wanted to talk
a little bit about is just other systems in
other countries that may overall be more efficient.
And one could argue, you know, part of it
depends on your perspective, but one could
argue that there's lots of inefficiencies
in in these systems.
One could argue that the means testing itself
is an inefficiency.
One could argue that the methods for policing
are inefficient.
There's a lot of different approaches to that.
But in terms of benefits and cost efficiency
overall, what should we be aspiring to?
What sort of examples in other countries are
particularly well-run?
Speaker 5: So I'm not an expert on international
welfare states, but I will say that there
is, I think, a very strong case to be made
for a universal basic income type of system
where you remove all of this administrative
overhead, all this bureaucratic red tape,
and create a much smoother flowing system
without all of these hurdles and barriers
and all of the associated costs and expenses.
And so people who are experts in this area,
at least to the extent that I've read them,
you know, generally associate a system like
ours that focuses on means testing with the
almost inherent or inescapable circumstance
of rule enforcement being a big part of it.
Right.
And this process of determining who's in and
who's out being a costly endeavor.
So in a system where you can eliminate those
administrative expenses, you're saving that
money.
So I think that there's a definitely a good
case to be made for more of a universal system.
I mean, something like we have now in the
United States, but just based on age for Social
Security benefits and Medicare benefits in
Speaker 1: such a system, what both when it
comes to UBI and so-called free college, there's
the criticism that you're also giving stuff
to the very, very rich.
Now, the very, very rich, statistically are
a small percentage of the economy.
But by sort of definition, is that something
we should worry about or not?
Speaker 5: But I mean, I won't tell people
what to worry about or what to not worry about,
but there I mean, there is an inherent logic
to a means tested system.
It makes a lot of sense, I think, in an abstract
world.
Yeah.
Or just, you know, on paper that people in
need should be the people that receive things.
But it just gets very complicated when you
come down to the process.
OK, what is neat, how are we going to calculate
that that's contentious in and of itself.
And then you have these these administrative
costs.
I think they're often not visible publicly.
Right.
Or not really prominent in the popular imagination.
And again, there is this inherent logic to
targeting aid to needy people.
But where the rubber hits the road, it's a
lot more complicated than just see who's needy,
give it to them.
Don't give it to someone who's not.
Speaker 1: Yeah, yeah, that's for sure.
That's for sure.
The book is Policing Welfare, Punitive, Adversarial
ISM and Public Assistance.
We've been speaking with the book's author,
Spencer Headwork, who's also assistant professor
of sociology at Purdue University.
So great having you on today and really appreciate
your time.
Speaker 5: Thanks, David.
It was a pleasure.